قال الكريم لان الرئيس الروسينا بوتن دعى
الجنيبه الاوكرانيه الى هدنه لمنح الناس
فرصه لاحتفال بعيد الميلاد وحضور الصلوات
واوعى الرئيس الروسي لوزير الدفاعيه
سيرجيسونغو بوقفه اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا
بدا من الساعه الثانيه عشر من ظهر اليوم
الجمعه حتى منتصف ليله الاحد
اعلن هدنه ووقف اطلاق النار لا يعني عدم
الرد على ما سماها استفزازات القوات
الاوكرانيه واضاف بوشيلا ان الهدنه التي
تصادف احتفال المسيحيين للاردنكس بعيد
الميلاد تعني مبادره لوقفه اطلاق النار
والاعمال الهجوميه من الجنب الروسي وليس
اعطاء الجيش الاوكراني فرصه لتحسين وضعه
العسكري والقتاليه على خطوط التماس
في المقابل رفضت كيف على لساني ميخائيل
بدلك المستشار في رئاسه الاوكرانيه الهدنه
المؤقته التي اعلنتها موسكو بمناسبه عيد
الميلاد وفقا تقويم الكنيسه الشرقيه
واعتبرتها ضربا من النفاق متهمه موسكو
بالسعي الى كسب الوقت بدلك اضافه في
تغريده على التويتر من على روسيا مغادره
الاراضي التي تحتلها في اوكرانيا وعندها
فقط ستكون هناك هدنه مؤقته مشددا على ان
كيف لن تنخدع بما سماه النفاق الروسي